as the Federal Reserve considers raising
interest rates today car buyers will be
watching closely the average monthly
payment for a new vehicle is now more
than 700 a month and more than 550 a
month for a used one adds up as much as
32 percent from pre-pandemic levels in
part because of higher interest rates so
what can you do to get the best possible
deal and drive the car of your dreams
off the Dealer's lot Nancy Chen has some
tips on how to navigate your way around
this very tough Market
at Lee Auto Mall just outside Portland
Maine it's been hard to keep cars on the
lot what's the average price of a car
right now the average price about 48 to
50 000. Adam Lee owns 16 dealerships and
says business has been especially good
the past three years but High sticker
prices fueled by high demand combined
with high interest rates are making it
increasingly challenging for buyers
we're still seeing very strong demand
but you can feel it that it's slowing
down although prices have dipped
slightly from historic levels new cars
still come out to nearly fifty thousand
dollars and used 28 000 on average
combined with aprs that can be as much
as 11 percent monthly payments are
skyrocketing one in six people who have
recently financed a new car committed to
monthly payments of a thousand dollars
or more the highest on record what is
the concern down the line if interest
rates keep going up most deal dollars
borrow money to pay for their cars and
at some point that will start to have an
impact if rates keep going up and people
can't buy cars it means we won't order
more cars so it locks up everything it
does
Demetrius Thrasher depends on his
vehicle to make food deliveries dressed
outside Atlanta after a crash totaled
his previous car Last Summer the Navy
veteran reluctantly purchased a new one
for about twenty five thousand dollars
more than he wanted to spend I called
around to the other dealerships
throughout the state of Georgia and they
were like we got nothing
Thrasher says he's now paying about a
thousand dollars a month for his car and
has had to defer payments twice he's not
alone delinquencies for auto loans 60
days or more past due is up 20 percent
from last year consumers are served to
double whammy because car prices are
high and interest rates are high Jessica
Caldwell analyzes Auto transactions for
Edmonds a car shopping platform for new
and used vehicles she says there is a
bright spot for those looking for a car
now we are seeing some automakers
actually offer incentives and we haven't
seen that in a while also make sure to
shop car loans for the best deal on
interest rates and terms and be patient
is there a sense of drive the car until
the wheels fall off I think that there
really is that sentiment and that
honestly is the best advice for CBS
mornings Nancy chin Westbrook Maine
we all know that philosophy drive the
car to the wheels come off better with a
couple cars in my family